what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we're going to watch the Guardians
of the Galaxy the holiday special today John
you're not koi how are you I'm great Greg
it's one minute five minute three minutes
and stuff how are you doing great coy already
watched this and I said it would be a lie
if you were here wanted to go to a theater
where James Gunn was there
anyway uh guys leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also uh subscribe click the
notification Bell to get notified when we
got a reaction up here in the channel that
you might enjoy Also full length Reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with your own
copy for Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
available for our super sexy rejects over
at our patreon page and we also cover a bunch
of stuff over there exclusively with reaction
highlights and watchalongs included special
thank you to all who have shown your support
over there trust me we've been dealing with
some BS copyright stuff lately so your support
means the world let's get to it
[Music] settling on sale
Ah that's cool you guys
is
that animated that's animated animated yeah
that's like 2D this one looks good what in
the fires of all guards I think you doing
hey Captain we're just uh have you ever heard
of Christmas what where everybody gets presents
for each other so Peyton Cracklin made this
tree and we got gifts for everyone it was
Pete's idea
it's more like a sign of appreciation that
sounds more like sediment boy that may be
okay for you mushy Types on terror but out
here in the cold rigors of space is what'll
get you killed and you you ought to know better
tisk tisk if it ain't on here before I get
back you both going to be cleaning the latrines
for the rest of the damn year but that's Jeff's
favorite job you're talking back now craglin
no
oh dude ah dude hey Christmas
buddy there's something there we need to uncover
I like how the animation was like an old school
Christmas movie yeah right now on Earth it's
almost Christmas time so yeah it kind of brings
back some memories you only got a point ever
since buying nowhere from The Collector we
don't have time for trivialities like Christmas
bought nowhere from The Collector that was
such a heartbreaking story I know stories
where everybody lives what use is telekinesis
if you can't even aim concentrate you stupid
mutton
what I refuse to do any more work while you
demean me so cute so glad they got a real
dog yes out on the third planet closest to
the Sun there's a special celebration and
it sounds quite fun a jolly old fellow brings
toys to everyone on a holiday they call Christmas
that's great it's beautiful
we're busy is this is this a long song nice
picking locks no if you don't get out he will
put dung in your socks that is not part of
the lore no no coal is not poop
it's reducing I have a flame thrower
nice
[Laughter] Santa's got to be rocking some
infinity stone energy
[Music]
[Laughter] this is gonna get a lot of play
this holiday season
dog and hold it up that deer lit up that deer
Christmas is but Christmas Time Is Here know
what Christmas is but Christmas Time Is Here
this is catchy yeah we need more in-universe
musicals I feel like I should do something
why because of you know my that you ate the
entire bowl of dog nuts in the commissary
my up they're your cool sister you should
just tell people the truth Our Father oh my
God maybe if we gave Peter a really wonderful
Christmas gift it would make him happy well
we could give him those arguments because
if you ate them all
yes ma'am over the years school has talked
about one person more than any other a legendary
hero who has saved countless lives we could
give him the quilt as a present let's do this
let's bag of some bacon hey honey hey baby
I can't wait for you guys to get back from
New York I would love if that wasn't actually
Kyra Cedric's voice I hope they stay together
otherwise this will not age well oh
rocks why are they staring you put the cloaking
device on like you said you did right yes
if you keep the [__] perfectly still you'll
be invisible
so we'll go down into the City and ask people
where giving bacon is I think Kevin Bacon
is the leader of the world are just in most
people [Laughter] in some ways we're all six
degrees separate from him yeah we could probably
go out and find him this is where all the
Marvel premieres are yeah we're just off screen
left
this is for Iron Man 3 took place
oh no
hi oh yes I'm sorry yes
I've got a picture with a God of War
out now he would be a good Kratos [Music]
oh no Drex laughs okay King goes
oh snap now you can make this a real restaurant
this is one of my favorite Saturday night
Hangouts box
give us your finest libations have you seen
Kenny where why would I know what Kevin Bacon
is like flula
my thoughts exactly
foreign
[Laughter] s of people on this planet we don't
even know what Kevin Bacon looks like you
want to know where Kevin Bacon lives it's
hard Maps classic move faster
do they meet all those people off screen yes
for the legend Dairy Kevin Bacon we're looking
for the legendary Kevin Bacon sorry guys I
can't help you hello
hello
do you think you can toss me over the gate
if you
godspeed
Drax got hops beautiful it's graceful probably
could just carried her over the gate yeah
this is not cool this is private property
now kindly put down my elf and my candy cane
and go I'm calling the police right now
oh yeah
you're coming with us as a Christmas present
there's two I don't know what they are people
are people costumes
why would you go upstairs with The High Ground
oh
my God that's great wow bacon got the Hops
as well I left my little funny man back in
the house what well how is it fair you get
to keep it and I don't because I I was responsible
and held on to it
[Laughter] Tom Cruise run it
you gotta get these things away from me hands
above your head stop
tickle it in my pants
oh my oh wow
damn Madness gets to kick some ass [Music]
sleep
kick names and Take ass [Applause] whoa yeah
you can't just kill people we are just taking
the legendary hero Kevin Bacon to give him
as a present to our friend who is sad about
Christmas okay here
oh I really wanted this but or even now we
would love to come with us hey where are we
going first there
clueless wow they had they they got everything
there assaulted police officers left a real
grinches when you had a small town by dancing
like an idiot well that wasn't me that was
a character that I played red McCormick in
the movie Footloose what what about when you
fought and defeated this super strong masked
killer Jason Voorhees in the world
he's never actually repugned it oh no profession
I'm you don't get to live just one life you
get to live so many lives we got quill the
worst gift ever a disgusting
Kevin Bacon you have to pretend you're an
actual hero or else Christmas is doomed fly
me mate I can't wait to storm them Nazis on
the beach no just your regular voice oh okay
yeah sure fine uh hello I'm the Batman and
I mean Hello I'm Bruce Wayne oh this is Bruce
Wayne this is so better James Gunn DC
damn group should join the high school football
team laughs
Smashing Pumpkins
oh that's gorgeous it's like Christmas Blade
Runner
oh
that is gorgeous I would love to visit that
get on at Disneyland yeah Bob Iger get to
it [Music]
Eric they dropped bacon back off nah he's
got to be around here somewhere he's gonna
like pop gotta have a dance off
damn sometimes looks like a guy in a suit
he really does yeah that's crazy
[Laughter] [Music] you must be Pete Merry
Christmas what'd you do what what did you
do we got you Kevin Bacon as a present you
got me a human being
Christmas [Music]
it's Christmas trafficking Mr bacon I am so
sorry this is really embarrassing I know you're
worried sick and your family is too we're
gonna get you back don't run you're not gonna
run [Music]
go get Kevin Bacon it's only because you mean
a great deal to Pete that they've done it
you saved a town for dancing and once Pete
saved the whole galaxy with dancing for real
now he might just be the greatest hero alive
hey aside from all the other Ventures yeah
man in these dopes they was just hoping you'd
bring the joy of Christmas back into his heart
is all oh you got a doctor who phone over
here yeah no I'm I'm just with some friends
would it be okay if I'm just a little bit
late oh Kevin Bacon you sweet son of a crispy
bacon [__] son of a Christmas [__]
[Music] yes uh bacon Bros in space so much
merch to be made for this one holiday special
so it was a Walkman God those effects are
like still mind-blowing my game boy it's my
old Game Boy insane facts man I wonder if
they aimed for like make it look like a suit
[Music]
that's fantastic
you too
[Music]
go nebula pop it lock it
oh I got the funny man
Ah that's cool
how did you know how to recreate that so much
merch to be made yeah I guess your Etsy store
going
oh he's got a star in his fin [Music]
where's the Silver Surfer
I love you Kevin Bacon hey I'll see you at
Easter oh yeah Easter special let's do it
Kragen told us the story about how he owned
a ruined Christmas so we wanted to save it
for you I'm not sure craglin knows how that
story ended
yondu liked Christmas after all I'm Rudolph
the red news reindeer y'all
he got Peter got that for him
from yondu uh
that is the coolest present I guess I just
wanted to do something special for you what
your father Peter he is my father too which
does that make you my sister
oh [Music] mantis that's the greatest Christmas
gift that's really touching [Music] it's a
Christmas miracle
I put down [Music]
Rankin and bass presents Guardians of the
Galaxy
that's nice when's the awesome Christmas mix
dropping what's the post-credit scene it's
Adam Warlock Mark Hamill the high evolutionary
it's Val Kevin Bacon from Hollow Man that's
that's the movie we need to bring back into
the public eye bring his character from X-Men
in here you can watch this every year but
how does it tie into the rest of phase four
in this startup phase five well it does I
mean I imagine some of this information will
actually be quite pivotal leading into Guardians
three there are some pretty important pieces
of information like what how they bought nowhere
name three things Cosmo because I'm about
to wonder out loud if any of those shots were
a guy in a suit I'm just gonna assume there
were no shots of any guy in a crude suit it's
gonna assume it was all great CG yeah it was
interesting how they did that [Music]
Jesus again [Music]
we gotta have another special confirmed
the Guardians will return next crisp that
was a really delightful special yeah warmed
my cockles
that's a real thing that's innocuous that
people say it's an innocuous phrase and I'm
not even because I had warmed my soul
I'll allow it oh I will disambiguate it uh
yeah that was that was really enjoyable I
like how it actually leaned into you know
when you compare it to something like werewolf
by night which felt like a a mini movie this
actually felt like a TV special but in the
most complimentary ways like you grew up on
like more Christmas specials than I did um
you know I didn't really grow up on them but
I've been introduced to them a little bit
later my fiance uh has shown me like several
so uh it didn't really go up on them so like
watching this I'm like oh this leans into
being like a Christmas TV special and it really
sets the stage for that with its animated
format the way it's bookended with it I'm
like oh that's really cool how they chose
that specific stuff not like the what if computer
animation but the the real 2D hand-drawn animation
and it feels like from an earlier era which
I thought was great but even the way he framed
it you know like it's not the way it's shot
is not shot like widescreen in the way how
he does like the films you know this has more
of a like the standard TV format the dimensions
of it is what I'm talking about so I and just
like the overall Vibe of it it does like when
you hear the word Christmas special holiday
special TV special that word special it it
does really accentuate that I think when watching
this so I thought it was great um yeah it
was just like really funny and charming and
the best mantis we've gotten thus far yeah
and I mean it's it's a testament I think to
the idea that sometimes it's good to have
especially looking at this looking at werewolf
by night I really hope they keep doing these
kinds of specials you know regardless of holiday
or whatever because it does give you a nice
opportunity to really focus in on something
and make something that you know has its own
type of impact and especially for something
like this I thought that they managed to do
something yeah is quite of the Guardians of
the Galaxy quite of the Marvel Universe but
it is scaled in a really nice way to match
like the classic tenets of the themes of a
Christmas or a holiday special you know the
idea of they don't like have to literally
save Santa from Peril or something like that
like Kiss has done in the past but you know
like in a way they do save Christmas and they
do sort of have to learn what the meaning
of Christmas actually is uh without it feeling
you know super wrote or like it's just playing
that one beat either like this felt like a
really well proportioned interlude you know
yeah yeah I do like I I think it also there
there's one thing I did find myself Desiring
from it um which I'll get into in a little
bit that I was like ah you know if they if
they if they if this was just a little bit
more enhanced I think it would have hit it
that much more in the end and I'll go into
that in a bit but I want to stay on top of
the things that I thought really did Excel
because the things with Drax and mantis I
thought um helped complement one of my I'm
I'm part of the camp that's not a big fan
of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. I'm I'm
I've seen it twice and both times I've seen
it I I just that one just was weird for me
because Guardians one is one of my top Marvel
movies and um James Gunn in general is like
one of my favorites but Guardians 2 just doesn't
quite mesh with me and only one of the aspects
of it that I wasn't a big fan of was like
the the comedy elements of what Drax got resorted
to and Jackson mantis and even though there
were some really funny parts but for the most
part I just didn't really find it that funny
and then here I actually think it makes that
in retrospect feel better even like their
their comedy bits in Infinity War the way
they play off each other like this got to
take Center Stage for the most part amongst
the characters that's the one that gotta take
Center Stage you know you've had the I am
Groot special group is usually a scene sealer
whatever groots in a scene even here when
grits on screen he can't help but like be
an awe or admirer take your eyes out you can't
take your eyes off of him uh Star-Lord obviously
the main star of the Guardians of the Galaxy
and uh nebula's had a lot of her own important
storylines so this was the chance to really
let the the duo of draxen and mantis but especially
mantis uh really shining I thought that was
cleverly done and this really did feel like
a Christmas um event you know I thought they
really leaned into that well because you know
as people who watch Doctor Who whenever a
lot of times it becomes a debate of like it's
a Christmas special really we were to just
like come out on Christmas day and you make
sure someone mentions Christmas so it's technically
but it doesn't really feel like Christmas
yeah that's something that really mattered
to me watching this was I wanted it to feel
like Christmas and uh Kevin Bacon I thought
did a really fun job too it looked like he
was having a genuine blast while making this
and he got a lot of uh fun little jokes he
gotta have in here as well and I like how
he the way he he comes around because it's
all fits within the tone of it all yeah you
know like his performance had the right tone
and everyone was on the right pitch of the
kind of tone this short this uh mini movie
essentially is so when he like does come around
to wanting to be of service on Christmas to
give him a good Christmas Day I thought was
great the part that I felt really uh I wanted
more of was not was leaning into star-lord's
emotion um because it was is so much about
cheering him up and they did have the thing
about him being sad about Gamora not being
there and I thought of they've leaned a little
bit more into that before the adventure really
took off or whenever or if they cut to it
in between while Drax and and mantis are out
on Earth having an adventure and then you
see that yeah like you know Christmas is I
think it was to be a very relatable thing
uh that people feel lonely around the holidays
and you know Star-Lord without having Gamora
around it you know I thought like okay if
we lean a little bit more into that that way
when the Christmas stuff does happen at the
end and he is so affected that like this really
did cheer him up but for the most part I felt
like while Chris Pratt had a few funny moments
and I loved his final scene with mantis uh
he was kind of just walking through the movies
for me yeah it wasn't really much of a presence
overall or that I was like it was more like
us more like I felt like Chris Pratt showed
up to play to dress up as Star-Lord for this
rather than I felt like I was with Star-Lord
yeah you know yeah I feel like if they could
have given him maybe just a touch of that
George bailiness like a minute or two which
is like a lot like just like a minute yeah
that's the show like he is really depressed
about not having Gamora around him give him
a true yeah sort of intimate or vulnerable
moment because he's mostly just going around
and you know coordinating things and like
dealing with people and it's in his performance
like you can tell that he doesn't seem like
he's chipper yeah he seems a little bit down
and he seems a little bit less energetic and
bombastic than normal yeah um so yeah but
that's why I was craving just to shine a little
bit more of a light on it because that works
for like subtlety but something like this
I'm like no I I didn't I felt like I needed
that scene just so that emotional Beats at
the end of ah they brought the joy of Christmas
here they're together now even though he's
sad you know like he doesn't even really have
a line about that yeah and I mean honestly
and and not to again it's not a big deal because
it also at the length that this is and what
kind of special dishes shooting for you know
you can't I guess you don't want to go super
long or eventually you're just making a movie
but uh but yeah I couldn't use a little bit
of that and maybe just to I personally maybe
wanted a little bit more you know it's like
I felt like with the wrap up at the end between
him and mantis that brought some catharsis
and especially spending so much time with
her and Drax like you said I really liked
the way that their Dynamic got to shine I
I would have maybe at the end liked maybe
just a to me it would have been like a beat
as maybe on Rocket Groot you don't need it
as much but I wanted to feel maybe more of
that real team Christmas catharsis like it
had a big like I know the point is to cheer
up Peter but I wanted to feel like it had
a big impact on everybody and it feels like
you know rock rocket is there you know he
gets he gets his gift it's a fun moment he
like there's certainly aspects of it but I
would have liked maybe just a little more
of that heart spell because rocket is also
a character with a pretty harsh past and and
you know some anguish in his General makeup
yeah well I I feel like utilizing the special
uh what was like because I feel like the point
was mainly to you know like you get to highlight
mantis more yeah and it's because this was
this was her she like if I were to pinpoint
a star of the special to her yeah yeah draxes
her back up yeah Drax is the main supporting
character yeah she's pumped Clement type was
turtle and she's great yeah she's amazing
in here like she was so funny yeah she was
she was hilarious and I love some of the comedy
bits too like I love the the horror comedy
moments of when she's like hopping on wall
like when you when you hop into Kevin Bacon's
perspective of how he must be of how he's
experiencing this yeah like these monsters
are coming after me it was funny it was really
really funny um and uh yeah I mean uh yeah
for me I I can't wait I do get what you're
saying I didn't find myself really this this
to me I was looking at the whole picture of
like everything from what the Guardians of
the Galaxy movies are and then the iron shorts
and then this yeah knowing that Rocket's gonna
have such a substantial thing to go on in
Guardians three apparently um with uh you
know you see baby rocket in there and stuff
so I'm like all right yeah I I get it like
this is gonna serve Us in between and what
I thought this special really needed was a
little bit more of that enhancement for the
the goal of why they want to cheer up Peter
that much you know which I get was more linked
to the memory of what went wrong with of how
they view what went wrong with Christmas so
that's why I'm saying like you don't have
to have it be in a bad mood you don't have
to turn them into like screws yeah like I
hate Christmas because that's not the reality
of the situation otherwise the twist wouldn't
make sense but the whole nice heartwarming
part with yondu which I thought was another
great uh thing to to include in here because
it reminds you of that the the the nuances
of their relationship was that yondu wasn't
always just an abusive hard ass guy you know
that he did really love Peter and did view
him as his son and especially since the last
time we were with yondu was in Guardians 2
which was like the one of the biggest talks
was yeah and so I like that when you check
in with here it brings you back to that version
of yondu at the end versus just leaving you
off with them like messed up memory yeah yeah
absolutely and I feel like it's one of those
things where where the ass like you know any
drawback brought on by the slightness it's
also a big asset because this is so good it
earnestly doing what it's doing and I liked
how Earnest it was like I feel like especially
you know like Marvel movies aren't averse
to earnesty but there's you know a lot of
humor and stuff that we gotta do and everything
and I thought this did really nicely to do
that but also just like I loved the Christmas
like when he's walking through and they're
turning on all the different lights it was
like truly dazzling and spectacular you know
in a just a a blend of as things I never thought
I'd have I would be able to think about where
it's like it's Marvel scale Christmas cheer
yeah yeah you know and I loved having uh that
must have been the old 97s you know as the
band and you know having this musical element
because you know James Gunn is obviously going
to bring his playlist of songs to have like
an actual that brought me back to like the
again having like that 70s 80s sort of Animation
yeah but then also having that variety show
like so many great Christmas comedy specials
and just various Christmas specials have like
a a music component of like people actually
playing on screen I felt like there's a grinch
Miss influence in here sure yeah um yeah definitely
and yeah I thought this was a really if it
was overall really fun there was something
else for sure that I wanted to quickly pinpoint
I like crackling a lot that's not what I was
going to say but I like Craig learn a lot
in here yeah um getting to see that really
endearing side to him too and uh because Cosmo
I hope has more screen time in gardens three
whole monologues worth in that Eastern European
accent that's a nice Easter egg with game
when her soldiers arm after infinity War I
thought I thought there was going to be a
post credits Bucky like wandering around perplexed
[Music] dismayed but that I like that bit
at the end with them decorating Groot and
all that stuff that was that was a nice little
like it was a nice little comic strip like
I do like that that also like it it does have
the feel of of a cartoon or a comic strip
well what I was gonna okay I remember I was
gonna say was that it uh I feel like I would
have had this assertion even if I didn't know
what the James gun I don't remember the word
for word what he was said but it was something
along the lines of how he had an idea and
he kind of wrote the first draft and he wrote
like the outline and like uh uh really fast
it was and he wrote the script really fast
and not in a way that was rushed it just sort
of like came down and I like scripts I do
like it when something feel has that Flair
of it feels spontaneous and fresh and exciting
you feel like they kind of cooked it up and
uh and and and it has it it kind of that Vibe
kind of carries through here in a in a positive
way because it's there's one thing when something
is rushed versus something that just was done
fast and spontaneous and I and I like the
vibe that I thought that resonated over here
the whole time too it's like when they're
giving each other the handmade gifts it's
it's like receiving a handmade gift you're
like this might not be like perfectly symmetrical
but it has it's all the better for it almost
you know yeah it has the cheer and it has
like you said I think spontane uh spontaneous
spontaneity is a good word because it does
feel that way and it has a lightness of Step
that I think is yeah helped Along by that
you know that bolt of inspiration sort of
uh momentum and that nice little Whimsy and
I and to me in in weird ways just from knowing
when you see like this feels different from
the Guardians of the Galaxy movies this feels
different from James Gunn Suicide Squad this
feels different from peacemakers you know
yeah so when you see like the versatility
there even though I know James come with DC
is going to be uh you know CEO producer he's
not gonna be directing all them you know it's
just to know that he's got a a knack for versatility
oh yeah is that because this doesn't feel
that like we just we watched a lot of Peacemaker
like this year was it this year no last year
last year yeah uh was last year I don't remember
I think so it goes last year I don't remember
uh it might have been might have been early
in the year I don't remember um but uh yeah
when did Peacemaker come out again I want
to say it was like August last year or something
yeah maybe but um your guess is is quite literally
as good as mine uh but not I I that's one
thing I really liked about it well and this
is it like it's certainly James Gunn but arguably
it's the furthest for what you would automatically
associate with James gun which I I do appreciate
him for yeah because it's not like a reverend
or I mean it's it's not crude yeah I mean
nebula says [__] at one point but that's
about it you know oh really I didn't even
catch up oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she says
it like right to the camera oh I don't remember
that but yeah anyway but guys I like that
we got the Cradle stroke because uh Dave Bautista
has been Fan cast as God of War many times
oh absolutely so I think that would be a it
would be great casting would be amazing casting
craters uh so yeah anyway what did you guys
think about the holiday special did you guys
really enjoy it give it like uh for what it
is or give it like a solid 8.5 out of 10.
damn hey you know I'll go eight eight eight
eight and a half somewhere in there I feel
like that's a nice little spot yeah yeah well
with that um leave your thoughts down below
you can check us on patreon and hey let's
do a
looking at your profile pic you're perfect
to shop for this a you got pizza the dog and
Kate Bish Haley Steinfeld got that [__]
over on your profile pic so you're a Marvel
fan that's for sure we got Cosmo the dog in
here we are doing a Guardians at the Galaxy
holiday special so you know what I wanted
to say to you Happy Thanksgiving Gabe I am
so happy that you are with us because your
support affects me greatly it's me personally
it I was on the verge of losing where I live
but because of your support I was able to
keep persevering that's a true story I was
telling this guy over here that I'm about
to lose it all man about to file bankruptcy
but Gabe to chose him John was like you don't
need to file bankruptcy you're fine financially
and I'm like no I'm gonna do it it's the next
step in my life I just don't think it's necessary
I gotta go bankrupt okay he's like why would
you ever choose to go bankrupt and then I
saw your pledge come in Gabe and then I said
you know what Gabe because of your pledge
it reminds me there's no need to sabotage
everything so Gabe you taught me a very important
lesson that if you don't need to go bankrupt
when you're financially fine don't do it because
I think everyone who's gone bankrupt is because
of that I wouldn't know the self-sabotage
man but I had imagined that it's probably
just some choice that they've made on their
own and uh not any other circumstances no
no one's no one's pushed to that point yeah
I don't see why they would unless there's
just negligence and laziness exactly um and
pure incompetence yeah I can't imagine any
other real reason why want and disregard yeah
it's just probably bad work ethic amazing
uh so but that's not me anymore because you
taught me that Gabe's pledge came in I said
I said that's it I'm gonna I'm gonna get my
life together I'm gonna to choose to get my
life together all right exercising started
going to therapy my therapist was even like
you mean you're here because of some person
named Gabe who pledged to your patreon said
that's right when I saw that notification
Bell come in I said I'm gonna get my [__]
together for Gabe like shouldn't you do that
for for yourself not just for this random
person I said screw you I'm getting another
therapist five therapists later I'm officially
not going to therapy anymore because I just
don't agree with what they have to say see
that's good that's that's staying true to
yourself and you inspired that Gabe I mean
hey I if I'm not gonna hear what I want to
hear then what's the point of going why would
I pay this person to help me if they're not
going to a firm racket the way I think so
Merry Christmas